tom brady go try to find a picture of  him out of shape the last 24 years the  best one you'll find is when he first  got drafted 199 pick you'll see a  picture of him standing like a bartender  okay from there on he's going to be in a  better shape today than he was when he  was 22 years old 21 years old going into  the nfl drake since 2008 7 whatever year  he's been in he's had hits after hits  after hits right  stink ray charles number one hits four  different decades we can go to hillary  clinton and donald trump now you may say  pat you're going to bring up hillary  clinton this has nothing to do with you  liking the competitor or donald trump  both of them have been relevant for 40  50 years  you know how hard that is to do  very hard most people stay relevant for  a year five years 10 years 40 years you  have to respect the opponent and the  enemy